[موسيقى]
هجوم الربيع المضاد الذي طالما استعدت له
اوكرانيا طويلا وحشدت له الاسلحه مستمر في
ثلاثه محاور بشكل متزامن في مسعا لاختراق
الدفاعات الروسيه وتظهر بيانات الجيش
الاوكراني والروسي ان هذه الهجمات تتركز
بالقرب من مدينه باخموت في دونيتسك خاصه
المحورين الشمالي والجنوبي في محاوله
لتكبير القوات الروسيه هناك خسائر
واجبارها على التراجع في المدينه التي
شهدت اطول المعارك
اما المحور الثاني فهو على الجبهه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا جنوب شرقي زابوريجيا
الذي تسعى فيه القوات الاوكرانيه الى
التقدم نحو تقماك والوصول الى ماريوبول
على طول الجبهه بنهر دينيبرو بينما تجري
معارك في محور ثالث قرب قريه
فلكانوفيسيلكا في اتجاه ماريوبول
التقدم الاوكراني وان كان بطيئا لكنه حقق
نجاحات باستعاده بضع قرن حتى الان بينما
تؤكد الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها تتصدى
يوميا للهجمات الاوكرانيه وتمنعها من
تحقيق اي تقدم من خلال هجماتها المضاده
وصلت وحدات من القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
محاوله القيام بعمليات هجوميه في اتجاه
جنوب دونتسك وكذلك لكن الاجراءات الشجاعه
والحازمه لوحدات مجموعه قوات فستوك صدت
ونشرت روسيا للمره الثانيه مقاطع مصوره
لمدرعات اوكرانيه غربيه الصنع مدمره واخرى
متضرره من طراز برادلي الامريكيه ودبابات
ليوبارد الالمانيه وفي المقابل ردت
اوكرانيا بمقاطع مصوره لقوتها وهي ترفع
العلم الاوكراني داخل قرى تمت استعاده
السيطره عليها مؤخرا